tudo bem tudo bem tudo bom
posso sou eu
bom vamos lá então é primeiramente
gostaria de contar como é que foi a
emocionante trajetória minha a 10 palco
como foi difícil chegar a esse palco é
quando eu falo emocionante difícil é não
falar minha carreira profissional dá
nome à minha vida pessoal eu tô falando
do trajeto mesmo daqui até aqui por
causa de bermuda e aparentemente não
pôde entrar de bermuda alguma coisa do
tipo eu tenho bom né
eu tô com um tênis e um cinto também eu
tô com uma camisa escrito louvando a com
a foto da banda klb e quando eu falei eu
sou palestrante amiga falou não não é eu
sou o pai não não é
foi mais ou menos uma hora para
conseguir convencer a menina enfim
consegui chegar aqui então você me
apresentar me chamo cid é eu tenho um
site chamado não salvo
eu tenho um podcast chamado não houve e
eu tenho um país chamado o pai do cid
o meu pai não tem nome na internet meu
pai o pai do sítio que eu acho ótimo
porque meu pai tá cagando para internet
isso é maravilhoso
o meu pai simplesmente não liga pra
internet é o meu pai é espanhol e 30 em
família espanhola sabe como é que é meu
pai da ele dá bom dia e parece que ele
está brigando comigo ele está me dando
esporro família espanhola é mais ou
menos assim é o meu pai ele tem 70 anos
e nunca precisou de tecnologia nunca
precisou de nada do tipo a e talvez eu
seja a última geração que teve que
aprender a mexer com tecnologia teve que
aprender a mexer na internet alguns de
vocês aqui também tem que aprender a
mexer com isso as próximas gerações as
gerações seguintes já está no dna da
criança olha a galinha pintadinha chama
a mãe né porque a galinha pintadinha
está criando ela é maluco isso a criança
olha uma revista e tenta passar como se
fosse um tablet
eu não estou inventando isso é real néel
uma coisa maluca e eu tive que aprender
mas na internet o meu pai tá cagando
a internet porque ele tem 70 anos nunca
precisou nunca trabalha com tecnologia
nunca precisou de computador pra nada né
então é uma coisa completamente
diferente até que os meus pais se
separaram e 20 anos de casado os meus
pais se separaram e o meu pai falou o
filho eu queria a mexer num computador
eu queria mexer na internet para
conversar com pessoas na internet e por
um minuto eu me senti pai do meu pai
porque eu falei meu deus do céu que que
sites ele vai entrar
o que ele vai fazer com que pessoas que
ele vai conversar vou enganar meu pai na
internet vão sabe vão se aproveitar do
meu pai como se eu fosse o pai do meu
pai né eu tinha essa preocupação porque
o ambiente que o domínio 100% eo meu pai
não entende nada
ele não entende a um ponto da gente já
ter feito uma mudança de ter colocado
microondas o meu quarto achando que era
tela do monitor e é real não é é ruim
então eu fiquei extremamente assustado e
eu fiz o que qualquer pessoa faria que
instalei um programa de acesso remoto no
computador do meu pai um programa de
acesso remoto é um programa que toda vez
que meu pai ligava o computador recebeu
uma mensagem avisando que ligou o
computador eu tinha total condições de
mexer em qualquer coisa dentro do
computador do meu pai quando digo fazer
qualquer coisa
são coisas do tipo ver o que estava
vendo por exemplo o que é um tanto
quanto perigoso ok você fazer isso com o
computador do seu pai é um tanto quanto
perigoso ou então ligar a webcam do meu
pai eu poderia ligar a webcam em ver ele
vem de alguma coisa o que também um
tanto quanto perigoso a quem não
consegue vocês a fazer mas eu estava
nessa nessa magia de querer entender
como meu pai ele entender a internet é
como é que ele enxergará internet né é
um mundo mágico seria uma coisa uma
novidade total por um senhor de 70 anos
é e eu resolvi criar um twitter para o
meu pai não sabe que o twitter
meu pai não sabe o que quer facebook meu
pai não sabe que é nada na internet né
eu criei um twitter pra ele e falei 'pai
isso aqui se chama google
ok tentei acompanhar o raciocínio falei
país a que se chama google foi o google
já ouviu falar na folha de são paulo o
google já vi uma matéria google é é é
grande é grande se chama google no
twitter né e eu fiz um background para
ele é diferenciado pra ele realmente
imaginar que era o google é inclusive
com uma frase muito interessante para
todos o senhor de 70 anos que ambiente
seguro de vírus é a frase mais
importante para qualquer senhor rock na
internet é se ele ter certeza que não
tem vírus é isso que importa na internet
e aí meu pai falou pouco interessante se
o google é pai é e aí
antes de começar a apresentar internet
meu pai eu pedi para os seguidores no
site a interagirem com meu pai eles
serem o google do meu pai entendeu então
meu pai é ter um google personalizado o
único e meu pai começou o twitter dele o
google com 50 mil seguidores
03 50 mil seguidores
uma experiência enquanto tanto maluca né
eu falei pra ele pra internet você pode
ser de qualquer jeito e escrever da
maneira que você quiser não se importa
com isso apenas escreve que o google tem
resposta para tudo mas na verdade que
estava respondendo nos seguidores no
twitter
ele não sabe não sabe a diferença né
e aí meu pai começou a acreditar a china
está fazendo pesquisas na internet e eu
comecei a transmitir o meu pai ao vivo
com a webcam ligada sem camisa
pesquisando bigode branco na tela e ea
tela dele aparecer e ele você via a
magia no olhar de uma pessoa que estava
mexendo na internet pela primeira vez é
uma coisa maluca né
e aí o meu pai começou a fazer pesquisa
uma das primeiras foi quero receita de
pudim normal né quero receita de pudim e
as pessoas começavam a receita já aí
podia talvez essa receita do pudim e
esse via é nosso legal onde estão vindo
receita pra mim que bacana mandar vídeos
de ana maria braga fazendo pudim e nossa
divertir
tal e aí começou a fazer pesquisas e
mais pesquisas precisam começar a ficar
estranhas do tipo papagaio tem dente que
pergunta isso né
teve uma pesquisa que ele fez que era
papagaio pensa ou só repete
é uma boa pergunta monta uma também que
eu me lembro bem que era existe pavão
femme à pergunta esse tipo de coisa na
internet os pais de vocês mas vocês não
sabem eu sabia que eu tinha essa
informação essa que é a grande diferença
né eu possa fazer várias perguntas
estranhas é óbvio de um perigo de fazer
uma pergunta errada ou sei lá que eu não
estava esperando é e aí chegou um
determinado momento que ele fez uma
pesquisa que foi a mais famosa até hoje
que era quero comer churros e é muito
legal porque é uma forma interativa eu
quero comer churros tipo está mandando
na internet não é isso é muito negativo
e as pessoas começaram a mandar chuva
pra ele ele gravado ao vivo e mandando
receita de churros e vídeo de quebra
fazendo churrasco e quero mandar um
vídeo pornô toma chuva saí e vi um monte
de coisa ímpar e você via no olhar de
desespero com tanta informação internet
mandando coisa pra ele eo que ela
mandava receita mandava vídeo da zona
florinda fazendo churrasco chávez e ele
não sabe o que está acontecendo é que
ele fechou o computador depois que o
cara mandou pra ele um mapa de santos
a escolha desse top do meu pai inclusive
um mapa de santos com todas as barracas
de chuvas na cidade
ele fechou um notebook me ligou depois
de uma hora falou filho à internet de
mais a internet demais que coisa
maravilhosa que internet
eu falei que ia comer churros e falou
demorava acho que o satélite pegou onde
morava deve ter pegou sua tese e já
mapeou todos os churros da cidade tinham
perto de casa fui lá comigo churros era
uma delícia
ele achou o máximo conseguido comer
churros através da internet né é o meu
pai foi influenciado digitalmente uma
pessoa que nunca tinha mexido na
internet é uma das primeiras vezes que
estava mexendo não é algo do tipo ele
foi influenciado diretamente uma pessoa
qualquer
na internet que mandou pra ele um link
de uma barraca de churros
essa foi a primeira influência da
internet meu pai a gente está acostumado
a mexer todo dia na internet é
influenciado todos os dias com uma uma
mensagem alguma coisa que alguém falou
alguma coisa aquilo fica na sua cabeça
assim como meu pai falou que queria
comer churros e um cara qualquer
mandou uma barraca de churros pra ele eu
pergunto pra vocês qualquer motivação de
um cara para o que ele está fazendo no
dia e mapear as barracas de chuvas na
cidade de santos para mandar pro meu pai
sem saber se meu pai vê sem saber se meu
pai vai clicar nessa relação é muito
maluca esse cara provável
mente e deve ser meu seguidor também
está participando da brincadeira então é
o primeiro momento que você pensa que
ele quer participar da história ele quer
participar daquela narrativa ele quer
participar daquilo que a gente está
fazendo é como se eu fosse um jogador de
vôlei será um armador de vou levantar
bola e um seguidor vem corta e encerra a
história né e continua a história
continua ea pontuação e isso é muito
louco você imaginar que existe um elo
tão forte que eu estou filmando o meu
pai sem camisa na casa dele o cara está
se importando com o meu pai lá querendo
comer churros e quer participar dessa
história né e é isso que a internet é
são pessoas criando histórias para
outras pessoas continuarem criando
histórias né é um mundo mágico é uma
onda no mar luco é que existe assim como
esse cara participou disso muitas
pessoas participaram de uma votação com
engolir um jogador da quarta divisão do
futebol goiano um jogador que ninguém
conhecia ninguém saber quem era é fez um
gol muito bonito inclusive esse gol aqui
fez um golaço de voleio mas vamos
combinar um gol da quarta divisão do
futebol goiano né da cei lá quantas
pessoas estavam no estádio mil menos 200
300 pessoas e ele iria concorrer com
nada mais nada menos que um dos maiores
jogadores da história do futebol mundial
leonel messi que fez e segundo ele passa
por sete adversários no estádio com seis
mil pessoas e faz um golaço no
campeonato europeu
e aí você se pergunta am enquanto os
seguidores têm um messi nas redes
sociais
qual a importância do messi no futebol e
qual a importância do homem deu liga que
nunca ninguém tinha ouvido falar no
futebol né e não importa no final das
contas a gente fez uma brincadeira pediu
para os leitores do blog assim junto com
desimpedidos que o canal de futebol
pedindo para votarem em de lira porque é
a primeira vez que a fifa liberava a
votação aberta na internet
ele pediu que o pessoal voltar não
intervirá em window lira chegou na final
do prêmio buscas
o prêmio mais importante da fifa contra
leonel messi que o carro não tinha nem
roupa pra chegar na suíça onde era a
premiação e
a gente fez uma vaquinha e conseguiram
os amigos e e conseguiu um terno sapato
calça cinto o cara a cara foi a suíça
participou da premiação e é maravilhoso
como a câmera começa a mostrar aos
jogadores a quem gosta de futebol sabe
que aparece o messi aparece neymar o pub
bar
o cristiano ronaldo e o engolir a ele
aparece na tela e todo mundo fica quente
cara né que ele está fazendo ea fifa
anuncia o vencedor e o engolir a ganha
com 74% dos votos em cima do messi
quais as chances disso acontecer
quais as chances de uma coisa dessa
acontecer na verdade nunca mais porque a
fifa percebeu que de repente isso tenha
sido perigoso e nos no ano seguinte ela
tirou a votação popular na internet
deixou um peso de 20% é mas é
impressionante você imaginar que o cara
subiu no palco fez um discurso e aparece
comece olhando pra ele concordando com
tudo o que ele está falando em português
concordando está falando vai lavando
davi e golias vamos e é uma coisa mágica
que só a internet pode proporcionar
porquê porque as pessoas querem
participar dessa história elas queriam
vê lo engolir a participar a gente criar
uma história criar uma uma novidade né
eu lia foi a coisa mais sabe que
qualquer jogador que ganha o prêmio
puskás de melhor jogador melhor gol do
mundo faria ele se aposentou e ele virou
gamer
ele virou um influenciador digital ele
resolveu virar um influenciador ele
criar as próprias histórias e faz
gameplay de fifa no youtube ele largou o
futebol faz gameplay fifa no youtube ele
é um dos top 10 jogo melhor jogador de
fifa do mundo ele ganhou do campeão
mundial de 6 a 1 esses dias um cara
muito muito bom e é uma história maluca
na época ganhou buscas depois ele vira
um influenciador porque ele achou legal
o que a gente fez ele quer fazer pra
criar as próprias histórias na internet
né ea internet basicamente é isso você
conversar com pessoas pessoas
conversando com as pessoas não são
marcas que fazem internet né não são
robôs
criam internet são pessoas que querem
criar histórias pra outras pessoas se
emocionarem rirem se divertirem ou
qualquer coisa do tipo
até mesmo quando a gente cria uma
campanha chamada molejo melhor bittles
fez um site inglês melhor que bits e as
pessoas levam faixa que moleza melhor
que bits molejão âmbitos sim é óbvio não
tenho dúvida nenhuma sobre isso é mas se
você acha que não não importa o que
importa você quer participar daquela
história você quer se envolver em
comunidade na internet ea internet
justamente isso
nós somos os traders mas quem realmente
faz as coisas acontecerem é o consumidor
do conteúdo ele sim é o protagonista
isso parece não gostar não é mauricio
cid muito obrigado
[Aplausos]